- Bonjour!
- François Legault remet
son chapeau de premier ministre
pour quelques heures.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Il y a des personnes qui ne
peuvent évidemment plus habiter
leur maison, donc on a
un endroit pour eux autres?
- Oui, effectivement. Il y a
quatre centres d'hébergement
qui ont été ouverts.
- Il fait le point avec la
sécurité publique sur les dégâts
potentiels dans l'Est-du-Québec.
- Puis c'est 130 km/h juste
à côté des Îles, donc ça veut
dire que c'est pas fini.
- Mais les équipes le rassurent:
il peut retourner à sa campagne
électorale.
- On a contacté
les quatre autres chefs hier
soir. On leur a expliqué la
situation puis on va continuer
de le faire toute la journée.
ÉRIC DUHAIME, chef,
Parti conservateur du Québec
- Ce matin, on voulait juste
voir la situation de ce qui se
passait aux Îles, puis quand on
té que tout allait bien,
on a continué.
- Mais il faudra faire plus,
pensent les autres chefs.
PAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chef, Parti québécois
- La totalité du nombre de
perturbations et d'événements
comme ceux-là, c'est assez clair
qu'il y a un lien avec
les changements climatiques.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
cheffe, Parti libéral du Québec
- C'est ça dont on parle quand
on parle de la nécessité d'en
faire un enjeu du 21e siècle.
C'est ça aussi.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS,
co-porte-parole, QS
- C'est un rappel qu'on doit pas
seulement lutter pour freiner
les changements climatiques,
mais qu'on doit aussi investir
de plus en plus poen plus poen .
- Le chef caquiste maintient que
son plan de 7 milliards $
pour une économie verte suffira,
alors que les municipalités
réclamenréclamenréclamenréclamer
se doter d'infrastructures
leur permettant de répondre
aux changements climatiques.
- D'ajouter 10 milliards
par-dessus ça, ça, c'est non,
mais les programmes qui sont
existants, je pense qu'il y a
une bonnune bonnune bonnune bone
pour les municipalités,
justement, pour s'adapter.- Fraà
prévu que sa campagne
le mènerait aux Îles-de-la-
Madeleine lundi.
Il juge maintenant cette visite
nécessaire pour constater
les dégâts et apporter
son soutien aux Ma